you talk about how when you grow up in
this situation you often don't have
people would assume well a young Sir
Patrick St would have Big Dreams you
didn't initially you thought I I guess
I'll be a lorry driver a truck driver
yep because you think you look at your
world and you think this is what's
possible yep and then what changed what
came along that made you think the
theater because the theater is really
the your passion in life you've had
obviously so much success television and
film but it's really the theater has
been the Dynamo in your
life what happened was a man called
cesil
dormund he was my English teacher in my
secondary modern school because I was
totally not academic in fact um you know
you you at the age of 11 you could go to
grammar school which was meant that you
had an academic potential or you went to
what was known as secondary modern
school and on the day of the
exam I was just um half a mile away from
the school where the exam was being held
just before you got there there was a
tea Junction and turn right and 200
yards away was the school turn left and
you go down theill Hill into the valley
where um murfield was built around the
river CER and the railway lines and the
canal cuz we had Canal barges and then
once you'd cross them you would climb up
in the beginning of the Dales on the
other side and you could look down onto
the town from up there and that's where
I went I turn left and not right
actually I've been turning left all my
life yeah which is both funny and not
but um so I didn't take the exam and so
I was never tested but I went to
secondary modern school and in my second
year the English master CLE dormand I
did I did something read something in a
class and he I saw him pay attention and
he was the first person to put a copy of
Shakespeare into my hand I never held a
copy of Shakespeare in my man and and he
it was just a surprise one day in the
English class and he was handing out
these books slim little books and said
all right this is U find Act 4 scene one
and uh okay you're playing uh Porsche
you're playing banio you're playing
Orlando and Patrick finally you're
wow and uh we read this scene
and my character didn't speak for a half
a page or so and then he had a speech of
about 40 lines which is one of the most
famous speeches in Shakespeare and
um I had no idea what I was saying I was
trying to say the words though most of
them I didn't understand and um and
yet something
happened I made a connection I
loved pronouncing these words I was
never I I I'd never spoken a language
like that out loud I mean I hadn't even
spoken English when I was a child I
spoke not just with an accent I spoke
dialect so uh do you want an instance
yeah I do
um this is this is my favorite uh if I
go to a neighbor's house to ask if the
lad my age is coming out you know for
kick a ball around or everything when he
came to the door I would say to him
that's Lake an
art
what what at a lake in art at a lake an
art at Art Thou because when I was
growing up we said thee and thou not
because we were religious at all but it
was just the way you know
workingclass West riding people spoke
yeah ATA art thou Laken now this is the
amazing
thing in Shakespeare's day actors were
also known as Lakers and I the word I
was using was playing Lakers stood in
for playing at uh are you Laken playing
at out oh my at a lak out it's funny and
you didn't know the derivation of any of
this you just know that's what it is you
just just saying you don't you don't
know what any of this is coming from no
nothing at all but the moment came when
uh a second teacher who was the my book
is dedicated to these two people um um
cesil dormund and Ruth win Owen who was
a retired professional actress now
living with her husband in Yorkshire and
teaching and um she said to me one day
you know Patrick if you really are
enthusiastic about
performing you've got to lose that
accent and so I started the next day
right away and for several years I spoke
with one accent at weekends when I was
going to my drama classes and one
accident Monday to Friday when I was in
school cuz if I talk like that in the
classroom whack I got thumped you know
no the other kids don't take kindly to
that ah gentlemen and kind women who the
does the thing that
ask sorry
d
I believe it's time for my jelly and
peanut
butter